I did not see recommended protocols in the members area for radiation treatment where there is daily oral chemo pill a days of radiation treatment, which is five days a week.
So if you're doing an oral chemo pill, you really can't do the chemo protocol. So the chemo protocol that we write about in the blog post is really for an IV drip of chemo.
For, you know, that takes place over a period of a couple hours and then you're going home and now you're staying away from, you know, you know, antioxidants that we discuss in that and we discussed multiple times.
And now you can go back on that. So typically I recommend if you're on a daily chemo pill, even if it's just five days a week for the period of radiation.
Or the daily chemo pill that many breast cancer patients go on that they're, you know, for years sometimes that you don't change your your protocol as far as nutrition goes.
You're still staying on antioxidants, you're still staying on your other nutrition. If you're doing an IV vitamin C or doing anything else, you don't really change that.
Now, you might not do IV vitamin C that, you know, during the five days of radiation. But you certainly go back to that to help pull that out of your body.
And that's another thing about this question here about what do you do to pull radiation out of your body? Well, using all your key lady type nutrition is going to be the best thing as far as a radiation protocol radiation treatment to pull radiation out of your body.
To follow up the next question before two, these are two whole wheel paths that we have we have our whole wheel path that can help pull radiation out of the body in this radio, radio legend, radiology, which can help pull radiation out of the body to.
These are just different whole your pets. Now, in truth, nothing is going to work perfectly. Our key later is going to pull radiation out of the body somewhat nothing is going to be perfect for radiation.
You know, that's the delirious effects of radiation on our body, they just it just can stay in our system like for you ever.
So whereas Kibo is a chemical that chemistry, you know, you can key late that and theoretically pull that out of your body radiation effects tissue and damages tissue that is more long lasting.
And you have more long lasting ill effects of that possibly too. So the more things that you could do to heal the better.